this age will be remembered as an age
where there was great wealth creation
there was great freedom's spread you
know there's a lot of poverty addressed
all over the world a lot of connections
remade and reestablished all over the
world the world became flat but I don't
necessarily know that that all those
positive things necessarily point to a
positive outcome because we have another
looming challenge with the environmental
crisis in a lot of areas and globally
and so we're about to be we're not about
to be we have been dealt a very very
large challenge and we haven't really
fully put our arms around it so the age
that I just defined would be more of
2010 previous and the era in front of us
I think potentially the largest issue
that will face would be environmental
could be war related but other than Wars
environmental I think it would look like
what's happening in Australia or the
environment wasn't that big of a deal
they had ozone problems people getting
skin cancer they started wearing you
know like right of the beach it wasn't
that okay the ozone is fixed great put
our head around that we fixed it but now
you've got the warmest months on record
and all of a sudden the entire country
of Australia shifted over to a very keen
sense of green candidate issues the last
election was won on green issues that's
going to be happening more and more it's
just it's just logical when water dries
up water becomes the commodity becomes
really valuable I live in Southern
California so I know that I had a
blackout a week and a half ago I'm
sitting at my pc had you know twelve
o'clock at night or whatever
all power went out it's happened before
in Southern California but not in a
while this is the first you know this is
California blackout so all sudden if
that's rolling blackouts and things that
are of that magnitude star happening
yeah shift everything shifts over there
I think that'll happen
you